everyone wants you to do well but just
not better than them I remember in the
early days of the gym when I was like
sleeping on the floor a lot of my
clients were like good for you chasing
your dream you know all that stuff like
really rooting for me you know within 9
or 12 months I had hired some people and
I had a manager and I was able to not
literally live at the gym sleep there
pulled up one day I walked in and like
four or five ladies who've been there
for a while were like ah Bossman see
you're like I thought you're too good
for us they were saying it in just but I
knew that there was like a hair of truth
to it that was when I realized the
truism